[Music]
this has been a hell of a newsweek and
i'm using that word in a very technical
sense it has been a hell of a really the
past couple of weeks uh huge
news on foreign policy obviously in
afghanistan on lockdowns here in the
united states
there was a glimmer of hope actually on
texas abortion law which we'll get to
but massive massive pushback from the
liberal establishment so a whole
variety of issues and and i figured the
only person
that i could bring on to help me sort
through every single one of these issues
is the least politically correct person
that i know
who happens to have more insight than
just about anyone i know that would be
jesse lee peterson jesse thank you for
coming on
thanks for having me on i appreciate it
so jesse i guess the the first thing we
should start with here is the good news
so we so rarely get good news that i i
have to bring this up this texas
pro-life law which for the first time
since 1973 means that there is a state
in this country where abortion is
practically speaking illegal the supreme
court has let this law go into effect
although whether it will be ruled
constitutional or not is still up in the
air the left is furious about it the
left is saying that if you are a man you
should have absolutely nothing to do
with abortion law
now jesse is f as far as i can tell you
are a man
last time i looked i watched you are and
i i suspect you have an opinion about
this even though the left tells you
you're not allowed to i do
one of the biggest mistake that was made
with this whole abortion movement
is that they convinced men to get out of
the movement because originally men were
heading up you know they were against
abortion they were fighting against it
and that's how we will win in the
abortion issues but when they convince
men that they have no right to say what
a woman should do with her body they
have no right to be involved in the
abortion movements the men got out of
the way
and the women took over and they went to
hell in a handbasket
because
it's not in the nature of women to lead
women were created by god to follow
not to leave so it's not in their
mindset
in their nature to lead and as a result
you have millions and millions of babies
that have been killed inside the woman's
womb
and so to hear what happened in texas
that is
almost it's still legal to commit
abortion after all these years i was so
glad to hear that i'm like what duh i
couldn't believe it i know it's so
unexpected that you would get some good
news it's funny too because i i can
already hear the heads exploding when
you say men and women are different and
men are perhaps better suited for a
leadership role but i'll tell you
something perhaps but they are it was
created that way by god well i'll tell
you do you know who would agree with you
on this because everyone's gonna out
there they're gonna say oh it's only men
knuckle dragging you know who agrees
with you on this my wife i we will we
will be sitting down
it'll be a friday night and we'll have
the most difficult decision of the day
which is where do you want to get dinner
from and i'll say i don't know you want
chinese food i don't know maybe i want
italian food i don't know what do you
want this you want that and it'll go on
and on and on forever until my wife i
kid you not she'll go hey buddy head of
household man up genesis 3 make a
decision
because
you know a lot of men don't really want
to make a decision but but there is just
in history
a leadership role that that has now been
completely inverted
absolutely and why do you think men
don't want to make decisions because
it's in their nature
given to them by god
god in christ christ over man man over
woman and woman children why don't they
want to make decisions i mean i can't
imagine not making decisions i i think
the reason that men i'm i'm not denying
that god says hey man you've got this
you're going to be the leader and hey
woman and you man you've got to love
your wife and woman you've got to do
what your husband says i'm not denying
any of that but i think because this is
a fallen world i actually i disagree
with what the the feminist left tells us
about men that all we want to do is club
people over the head and drag our
knuckles i think what men really want to
do if we've just pursued our basest
appetite i think we would lie on the
couch all day and eat potato chips i
think actually the thing we have to rise
up to do the thing we have to get the
strength and confidence to do is to make
decisions and i think it's it's when men
act like men when they do make decisions
when they stand up i think society tends
to work better
than when men act contrary to that way
when i was growing up and they i want to
come back to this abortion thing and
text about when when i was growing up it
was that order
my father
led my grandfather led other men led
they were over their wives
and children and the women knew it and
they respected that and as a result of
that even there was
a thing called jim crow law grew up
under that law it did not affect black
people at the time because of the order
of god they knew that it was a spiritual
issue
the blacks knew that it was a democratic
party that did not want the blacks to be
a part of the party and most blacks at
that time were republicans and that's
why they founded the republican party
and so the jim crow law did not affect
us in the way that they are pretending
that it did the blacks in the way that
they're pretending today they have
rewritten history in order to control
white people so that they might gain a
perceived power and wealth but when that
family is there when that order is there
there's nothing that the world can do to
hurt you because you're of the father
and not of the world and you're in it
but not of it and until we come back to
that order you're going to see some
miserable people in this world because
they're not being guided by the order of
god that men men are the light of the
world and women are the darkness of the
world and so
don't you think that's a little that
seems a little harsh to me is that not
but it's true it doesn't seem harsh to
me it just seemed to be the truth
so we need to speak the truth shine the
light on the darkness so we can change
it
uh the god above is the mascot and the
god below it's a woman's god and so
whenever you put women in charge whether
it's of the home or the i mean of the
children or of the government of school
you get nothing but hell
look at the things that have been
brought on earth since the women have
been in charge
things that we never imagined would
become
uh pretend to be a norm like same-sex
marriage and
lgbtq and
uh
radical black women taking over the
country and all kind of mess
that's happening
the military is weak now everything is
weak
as a result of the women taking over
because the hell come through the woman
and the love come through the man from
above well i certainly agree that when
we've completely inverted the order of
standards and taboos and morals and
norms i agree that that has led to hell
on earth but but don't you think jesse
that if you if you look in scripture and
it says that man will be the head of
woman as christ is the head of the
church and christ is the head and the
church is the body of christ i i think
it's fair to say that you know it's it's
not that the church is evil and and
christ is
good or that you know women are evil and
men are good but that that there's
actually just an order to all of this
and it all can be made good by turning
toward god or you can turn toward the
other guy and then things aren't going
to go very well
well we need to understand that order
though and forth in order for that to
happen because churches today have no
understanding about that order they know
how to preach the bible or teach the
bible but they don't know god they are
uh they are intellectual bible thumpers
and they have a theology just as the
same as the intellectual have science
but they don't know god and unless
you're born again of the father god said
that there will come a time when i'll
return the children to the fathers and
the father back to the children when you
return to your father then you shall
know god because all men represent god
they're weak and better most of them
because they've been turned
because they've been turned away from
the father but when they turn back to
the father by forgiving their mothers
for turning them away from the fathers
then that order will come together and
women will have a chance to live too if
the men were to come back to the father
so they could draw the woman out of
their hell
back into paradise into his heaven and
unless that happened every time the man
goes into the woman's world he will
suffer because the woman does not have
the answer the man has the answer she
looked into the man
as the man looked to christ
and i would
the body of god the church of god is our
body the men bodies god dwells in us the
kingdom of heaven is within and so our
body is the temple of god and it's there
we should worship him it's nice to go to
a building and fellowship together
but we should worship god from the
temple from within he is within us now
and that's when we should live from
within and not from without well and it
certainly it's you know on this is true
in the church and it's especially true
in the family that building block of of
political society that when there is
discord there
that is going to radically affect a
child's life it's going to affect the
whole community and especially if the
family splits up if the husband runs off
or he gets booted out for that matter
that's going to have a profound effect
it does on
on basically everyone who's gone through
it that i've talked to and so what one
point that i've heard democrats make
with regard to this texas abortion law
is they've said well you know what
if uh if women can't get abortions then
i think we should force men to stick
around and raise their kids and i think
they're they're saying this as though
conservatives are going to disagree with
that to me that sounds like a great idea
that's a perfect idea to me i love that
idea as a matter of fact in the good old
days when boys were boys and men were
men
if there was a divorce the children
would go with the father and not with
the mother because we knew that the the
father was the best for the children and
so we need to go back to those days when
the children if there have to be a
divorce that the children should be left
with the father and not the mother
so i love that idea i'll tell you though
jesse i mean i'm all really i think we
just need to reduce divorce dramatic
make it harder to get a divorce i think
no fault divorce created a lot of
problems in in the country led to a lot
of the gender confusion and the sex
confusion but i will tell you as the
father of a seven month old baby
there is a just a kind of
biological nurturing thing at least with
a little baby that i i feel that i'm not
quite as good at you know my baby will
literally he'll occasionally try to
breastfeed on me i'll say listen you've
been reading too many gender studies
books that is not going to work my man
that's right um and that's why you need
the wife there another reason because up
until about three years of age the
children need the mother to give them
all that you know breastfeeding and
everything
yeah but after that the children should
be turned over to the father
so that the father can guide the
children in the right way to go and they
will grow up in perfect love and you
wouldn't see all this mess going on
right now uh in our country because the
light of the father would dwell in the
children and they would become what the
father is and we will have peace on
earth instead of hell on earth so we
definitely need
a marriage between a man and a woman one
man one woman that would last until
death do your part in the good old days
it was that way men and women got
married because god brought them
together and whatever he brought
together no one can divide it no law no
in-laws or anyone else but nowadays
these marriages when they do happen they
are not under the umbrella of god the
under our brother of satan and that's
why they don't last and it's easy for a
law to be passed and to separate the
family and all kinds of things but we
must bring that order back because what
god put together you cannot divide it
you can't take it away well a lot of
today what passes for marriage i think
is really quite alien to marriage i'm
not even talking about same-sex marriage
or any kind of redefinition i'm even
just saying men and women i i have i
have friends of mine who refer to their
wife or their husband as their partner
like it's an accounting firm
when did that happen that doesn't that
doesn't sound like love to me that
doesn't sound like a marriage to me
it's it sounds like a homosexual
relationship what i hear and
so when i hear men or women saying well
my partner i'm like are you married to a
woman because it's d it's d gender right
it's it's the sex is totally taken out
of it
what happened was uh our society a lot
allow the radical homosexuals and the
radical feminists to change the title of
husband and wife to partner because they
wanted their phony relationship to
appear real to and so if you don't say
husband and wife it made two men or two
women that are together under the
presence of husband and wife it made
them feel good about being wrong they
forget that what they're doing is wrong
but when we say husband and wife man and
woman it reminds them that they are
wrong and they don't want to hear that
because they don't have a conscience
and so they don't want to be reminded
that they are wrong that's why we cannot
go along with evil we have to call it
what it is we have to say no it's not a
partner this is my wife and the wife has
to say this is my husband
and not go along with the lies because
when you change the wordings you also
change changing from the light to the
darkness and that's what you're going to
have in your life well there's there's
no question that the manipulation of
language i think this is the number one
way that the left transforms culture and
what i would disagree with though is the
impulse for that i actually think it's
because the left and even beyond any sex
questions or anything i think the reason
the left changes the language all over
the culture is actually because it does
have a conscience so it i think the left
knows for instance that an illegal alien
has no business being in america but but
an undocumented american well he's an
american of course he has every right to
i think they they're aware of that
they're they're trying to redefine
reality what i want to get to though
jesse before before we move on to these
other issues i want to go back to a
point you made a very very interesting
point when you said everyone talks about
jim crow now but actually jim crow is
not as bad as people are making it out
to be you know it doesn't sound like it
was exactly pleasant and it had plenty
of injustice and all of that but but it
seems to me what you're saying is the
far greater problem for the the black
community
is the breakdown of the family than even
the most atrocious law that could be
passed by the government
one hundred percent
i do remember the difficult lawsuit i
remember for colors only signs were
blacks only i went to a movie theater
once down in uh alabama when i was a
teenager and we had to sit the blacks
had to sit in the balcony and the wife
sat down stairs but we didn't think it
was a bad thing because we had better
seats upstairs than they did downstairs
we had fun
surely some people didn't like it
maybe it was a mixed crowd i don't know
if it did i wasn't aware of it i mean i
had a bunch of black friends i grew up i
went to all black school
and uh we would go to montgomery alabama
to shop and visit in another little town
you fall alabama and i never heard
blacks really
carrying on if though someone was
holding them back
because during that time yes we knew it
was there
but but because and i know because we
have family because we love god we love
what was right we knew that it was a
spiritual battle between good and evil
right versus wrong and the older black
people would say all white people don't
agree with this all white people don't
hate black people treat others the way
that you would like to be treated and so
we lived by those principles and because
of that we were doing fine uh i know
blacks who bought land as a matter of
fact my uh one of my aunt got married
and she and her husband bought a bunch
of land they had like 19 18 or 19
children
and they their children uh went to
school every day and they worked on the
forum after they got out of school that
day but and they all went to college and
graduated from colleges around the
country my best friend and he and his
family had the same thing going on my
family bought land it didn't hold black
people back but once that civil rights
movement started which were one of the
worst mistakes in america today we
should not have allowed that to happen
because this so-called civil rights
movement
it
it sold out to blacks it deceived them
to make them think that they were worse
off than what it really was
and so at some point
they were able to divide the races by
calling white people races and all this
stuff
and they got to a point where they made
a deal with the democratic party martin
luther king jr and all those guys they
made a deal with the democratic party
that
um
if you let us be the leader of the
people the so-called black leaders they
want to be the leader of the blacks we
will sell the blacks over to you
to the democratic party and you have to
give them free stuff
and so they agreed to give the blacks
welfare at the times and they made the
men the black men feel like
you were the women feel like they didn't
eat the men anymore and a lot of people
start to fall for that and it's just
been downhill ever since because not all
not all not all not all but most black
people are not thinking for themselves
now they listen to what so-called
democrats say or their leaders say
or some preachers saying whereas before
we had no leaders we thought for
ourselves they are no longer doing that
and now blacks are in a mess i mean i
never
imagined that black people would be as
hateful
and evil
and destructive
and blaming and whining
and trying to take and hurting someone
i never imagined that they could get to
that point but because they have no
values they don't believe in god they
don't love him they're again in that way
i mean they are that way and if somebody
don't tell the blacks are true they're
only going to get worse
before they get better they're robbing
and killing and stealing and raping not
only other black people but white people
the uh asian community they're knocking
people out and taking their stuff and
getting away with it because they don't
have to go to jail anymore they don't
have a bail bond so there is no
punishment and since they don't have a
conscience they now don't have the law
of the land to stop them it's going to
only get worse unless the people speak
up if you doubt me look at south africa
the blacks are ruling in south africa
and they have defunded the police over
there white people have been pushed into
a corner and they're being robbed and
raped and
beat up along the highway and raped in
their own homes now they're taking their
land and white's land without
conversation that is happening here
because white folks will not speak up
somebody got to tell the truth or the
blacks are going to get worse you
haven't seen anything yet well to your
point especially on the on the
prosecutions with the blm riots and the
looting and all of that in manhattan and
in the bronx
many if not most of the people who were
picked up for looting for that sort of
riding were just let off the hook and
and even serious offenses were pled down
meanwhile you've got the horn guy from
the capitol riot you know you've got the
guy the the trump guy smiling with
pelosi's lectern they're going to get
the book thrown at them i mean they're
going to be in prison for a very long
time so it's obviously unequal and i
just i love this point that you're
making here which is we are told a
narrative about the 1960s and all the
great advances that it made for race and
how how the black community was so
helped and advanced during this era but
what you're saying is we'll look at the
disintegration of the black family look
at the spike in crime rates the rates
had been going down until the 1960s then
they started to go in the other
direction look at the spike i mean look
at spikes in in poverty in certain
places i mean that there's a there's a
it seems like there's a negative side to
that history too that is totally papered
over
that's right
when i was growing up crime was unheard
of from black people really i know it
was happening i guess but in the big
city somewhere but in alabama where i
lived and i lived near montgomery and
other big towns around there uh crime
was unheard of because children grew up
knowing that the parents were not put
would not put up with that and so they
respected their parents and they didn't
go out robbing and raping and stealing
and killing and breaking into people's
homes and their cars and things like
that because they were afraid of the
punishment that would come from from the
parents first i remember
when i was growing up my grandparents
especially my grandmother used to tell
me
if you commit a crime
you're going to jail i'm going to make
sure you go to jail i'm not going to
accept collect costs i'm not putting
money under books
i'm not coming to visit you go to center
jail until you rot or they let you out
and they didn't play around and if they
did hear of other bad children they
would not allow us to play with those
kids or even go to their homes the black
kids because they knew the parents were
no good because they could see it in the
children that's how much
how respectable and value and love was
right and love this country that black
people were when i was growing up and we
made our own opportunity we didn't rely
on just the white man to to make
opportunity for us
because we never thought
that anyone was holding you back and if
somebody tried to hold you back we knew
it was a jealous person trying to hold
you back and they couldn't help it
i i cannot understand
that
i don't
i understand it now but it's crazy to me
that in america today
that someone can believe that someone
can hold them back
can no one hold you back and let you a
lot unless you allow that to happen but
i do realize michael that most black
people not all not all not all but most
black people believe that white people
are superior to them
and i hear it all the time that white
people are white supremacy i hear from
the i hear it from the blacks more than
i knew the whites so it's not that if
white people think that way of
themselves
it's just that the blacks of such losers
now they think that white people are
naturally superior to them you're
hearing this taught in schools now i
mean you are you are now seeing a whole
generation of students being taught that
if you are black you are you're not
gonna succeed and if you're white you
are and that's just the way don't even
try buddy because it's it's over you're
you're a loser and you you can't you
can't make anything of yourself and i
just think that is the most destructive
perverse thing you could possibly teach
a kid short of little boys should be
little girls which they're also teaching
them in the schools
i know
i can't even imagine an adult teacher
telling any child or children that they
can't make them because of color
and i can't imagine a parent allowing a
teacher to tell their children that it's
just that they've gotten so far away
from god they have no values
that these things they can't really see
what's going on they don't i don't
it's just crazy they're they're selfish
parents now and selfish teachers it's
all about self and not about the
children and they just don't care what
they're doing to the kids but white
people
better start speaking up because this is
all going to come down on them
they're putting these radical radical
radical black women in our government
in our schools
in this uh uh they're becoming mayors
and and city council men and stuff like
that police department these people are
wicked what do you think gonna happen
they have already destroyed their
children there's no way they can make
america better they're only going to
make it worse in san francisco michael
they passed uh
if they haven't passed they're working
on a law that says
to the criminals in san francisco
california if you don't commit a crime
we're going to pay you 300
a month
not to commit a crime that's nice work
if you can get are they going to mail
that to me i promise i won't commit any
crimes in san francisco where's my check
that's right and then they say if you'd
be real good we will give you 500 a
month
isn't that amazing
that is amazing jesse and they have a
female black female in charge of san
francisco she's the mayor of the city
this is why this is happening we need to
put men back to order bring back their
hold on i don't know how you sit around
and come up with an idea like that
michael and think that is good but i
gotta i got i'm not defending the mayor
of san francisco but
you know
sure she's a black woman but then you
look at gavin newsom he's a white man
he's doing a pretty bad job running the
state of california so is it is it
really just a sex thing or race thing or
is it it seems like it's this
kind of steeping leftism that is just
it's just kind of permeates everybody
but gavin newsom is he has a female
mindset and emotion he hasn't overcome
his mother in return to the father you
know god said we must be born again
and he we have to all who are born
through the woman is dying they are
dying that's why you must be born again
of the father and those who return to
the father living gavin newsom clearly
has not done that he doesn't have the
mindset of a man he has an illogical
mindset of a woman and so that's why he
operates as a woman because he's his
mind is not normal and he he has all
these emotions and so he's operated on
what he think and feel and he want a
false sense of power so that he can feel
better about himself obama did the same
thing
but
the father messiah barack obama
he's he almost brought america to her
knees
because he hate his father yeah he grew
up with his mother he hated his own uh
he hate the white race because his
mother hated the white race and i write
about that in my book the antidote
healing american from the poison of hate
blame and victimhood obama hated his
father
uh he hated the race and he had the same
mindset that his mother and grandmother
had and so when he became president he
did the same thing that gavin newsom and
other liberals are doing they operate
from evil and not from good people must
understand
our battle is a spiritual battle it's
right versus wrong good versus evil and
if you have not returned to the father
you won't be able to see
that it's not about color it's not about
male or female it's about good versus
evil right versus wrong and the liberals
are on the side of evil and they can't
help it and they they
they have no power they only have
intimidation if they can intimidate you
they can control you but if they can't
they have no power that's why good have
to overcome evil well it's it's
certainly true also that if you're
interested in daddy issues the united
states presidency is probably uh ground
zero you've seen it played out a lot
over the years and certainly with barack
obama just that first book dreams from
my father about a man that he he barely
knew and obviously it made an impression
on him speaking of
the presidency speaking of
the country collapsing
i need to ask you this question jesse
because you don't seem to be very keen
on democrat black women being in office
but you don't seem to be very keen on
some of these white guy democrat
politicians either so this brings us to
the question of
should we impeach joe biden you impeach
joe biden you get kamala harris so you
you say yes we should
yes and the reason for that
my personal opinion i haven't seen any
medical records or anything like that
i'm joe obaya
but my father my earthly father he died
of alzheimer's and i can remember when
he first started developing it he will
forget things after a while he would
look as though he's looking at something
but not looking at it
uh he would remember and then he would
forget
and as time progressed he got worse joe
biden clearly reminded me of that you
remind me of my father going through
that alzheimer's disease thing and so i
personally don't believe that joe biden
is in charge anyway yeah somebody else
are making the decision and they prop up
joe biden and put the letters in front
of him and say read this
don't say any more unless
just read this no questions
so uh camilla harris and others well
camilla harris doesn't have systems
enough to lead so i i can't believe
she's leading because she even dropped
out of the race when she was running
against nobody remember she was the
first one ever
yeah and so because the folks in
california didn't want her but joe biden
is not into short in charge now somebody
else is already controlling it so if we
should impeach joe biden it's just going
to be the same people in office anyway
the obama i don't believe is leading at
all
he's just doing what they tell him to do
right just a sort of empty suit he's
been an empty suit his entire career but
i agree this there is a there's
obviously a spiritual dimension here to
the principalities and powers that
govern this world and the sooner we wake
up to that spiritual dimension probably
probably the better off we're going to
be jesse we got to leave it there uh as
always
a great pleasure to talk to you where
can people find you
they can go to rebuilding the man.com
rebuilding the man dot com on jessie lee
peterson and or
jesselypederson.comjesselypederson.com
mike it's always fun to talk to you man
you too jesse you are to to really wrap
up our whole topic today you are the man
and i look forward to talking to you
again soon
thank you man
[Music]
[Music]
you